with las vegas resorts fully open and
coped restrictions now gone that also
means
paid parking on the strip is back it's
only a matter of time brandon
absolutely and some major properties
starting to charge guests
today orc o'man and joining us live in
the strip with the changes and also
where you can still park for free orco
well brian and denise starting today mgm
resorts
properties on the las vegas strip all of
them will have
paid self parking that includes mgm
grand here behind me you're taking a
look
at itself parking garage and it also
applies to hotel casinos like the
bellagio new york new york and mandalay
bay
but here's the good news if you live
here in las vegas self parking is free
for locals for the first three hours
at mgm resorts properties you just need
to show your nevada id
paid parking is also now back at the
cosmopolitan
and caesars entertainment properties had
already started charging for self
parking
back in october we asked visitors what
they think about these fees
it's something personally i don't really
like you know normally i know they make
money plenty of ways through the casino
so especially during the week i think
they shouldn't necessarily ask
for us to pay i'd rather park somewhere
far and then walk to where i need to be
instead of park
like 30 dollars
[Music]
ok so now the big question where can you
still park
for free take a look at this map free
south parking is available for everyone
at the tropicana treasure island the
strat sahara
circus circus planet hollywood the wind
and encore as well as the venetian
and the palazzo now valet parking is
also available again at
most resorts but you do have to pay for
that mgm resorts properties say
that if you are an m life rewards member
some of those members
will get that complimentary reporting
live near the las vegas strip tonight
orca mana 8 news now
an orco we asked on twitter do you think
locals should pay for parking
at all 15 percent say yes support our
resorts 85 percent
and ted wayne in from afar say no we
live here